knapp ein meter wasser unter dem kiel
die ms karl hein ist in rotterdam
gestartet auf dem rhein geht es nun bis
nach mannheim
bei niedrigwasser werden fehler
besonders schnell bestraft ein frachter
hat sich in ufernähe festgefahren
er liegt einfach zu tief und
muss jetzt probieren dass er irgendwo da
wieder irgendwie freikommt der
verunglückte versucht sich heraus zu
wühlen mit voller motorkraft
binnenschiffe ralph kiepe ist
vorsichtiger auf seiner tour gegangen
statt der möglichen 4000 tonnen ladung
hat er nur 600 an bord genommen auf dem
wasser armen rheinfelder 36-jährige
nichts riskieren
[Musik]
hatte hochkippe stößt dazu dass
schriften der erste der letzten
wer liebt zu tief
ein vermeidbarer fehler findet auch der
vater ebenfalls kapitän es gibt so eine
app die haare jeder partikuliere seine
erfahrungen hier auch eine app gibt und
darauf wird dann eine fahrrinne
gezeichnet sei es jetzt am tiefsten und
dunkelblau auf lassen und da wo er sich
nun geglaubt zum helfen bleibt den gibt
es keine zeit sie haben autoteile
geladen mit strenger lieferfrist der
rhein eine lebensader der wirtschaft
80 prozent des güterverkehrs der
deutschen binnenschiffahrt finden hier
statt doch jetzt bei niedrigwasser
sinken die frachtmengen deutlich
hier hätten hätten wir auf jeden fall
noch platz für ein paar container aber
dann wäre das schiff hinten zu tief
gekommen und somit können wir hier nicht
mehr laden auch leere container während
zu schwer gewesen das werden wir das
schiff bekommen und hier ist noch platz
für ungefähr 25 container hätten wir
hinten so noch hinstellen können ralph
kiepe vorsichtig genug die nächsten tage
werden ist zeigen
wenn der wasserstand im rhein sinkt
wächst die aufregung bei vielen
unternehmen
energiewirtschaft baugewerbe
lebensmittelindustrie
sie alle warten auf die grundstoffe für
ihre produktion ohne binnenschifffahrt
droht stillstand
über die neuen werden vor allem
vorleistungsgüter
rohstoffe grundstoffe befördert
beispielsweise chemische erzeugnisse
kohle oder ärzte und wenn es hier zu
ausfällen in den transportwegen kommt
kann das kettenreaktionen in der
wirtschaft auslösen schlicht und einfach
weil diese produkte zu beginn vieler
produktionsketten stehen genau das
abzuwenden ist die herausforderung für
logistikunternehmen sie sind es die
dafür sorgen dass kohle zement oder
getreide dorthin kommen wo sie gebraucht
werden wenn die binnenschiffahrt stockt
müssen die container auf bahn oder lkw
umgeladen werden das ist viel teurer
das wird weitergegeben an den kunden und
bei den zügen ist es so dass man so
sagen kann anderthalbfache teurer als
das binnenschiff und der lkw ist bis das
doppelte oder dreifache ein mittelgroßes
binnenschiff kann so viel ladung
aufnehmen wie 100 lkw 20 tonner
wenn all diese ladung wegen des
niedrigwassers auf der straße unterwegs
ist belastet dass die wirtschaft und die
umwelt
das ist tatsächlich auch so dass dadurch
die ökobilanz und von uns allen dadurch
verschlechtert wird und es kostet auch
viel merkel zurück auf der ms karl hein
hat binnenschiffer heinz keeper eine
ruhige nacht hinter sich noch ist er in
den niederlanden das radarbild zeigt nur
wenige seichte stellen an denen er das
tempo drosseln muss höchste
konzentration ist dennoch gefragt weil
jedes schiff nur wenig fracht aufnehmen
kann sind mehr davon unterwegs als
gewöhnlich
der rein so niedrig dass die kühe ein
bad nehmen können bestaunt dieser
pegelstand so früh im jahr
habe ich in meinem leben noch nicht
gehabt ihre juli august jetzt ist es
eben mit einem sommer und wir wissen
nicht was diesen herbst erwartet an
dieser voll mir herbst trocken und kalt
wird kann
es sein dass die schiffer zone zum
erliegen
deshalb arbeiten vater und sohn zur zeit
durch und sparen für eine mögliche
zwangspause sie wollen auf alles
vorbereitet sein das zeigt sich auch
hier an deck liegen zwei ersatz
propeller falls sie doch mit ihrem
schiff auf grund laufen sicher ist
sicher
man weiß ja nie gerade jetzt mit dem
niedrigwasser kann da sehr schnell mal
passieren dass da ein großer stein oder
so oder irgendwas war es im flussbett
mal durchkommen auch firmen andere
kimpel kontrolliert täglich voller sorge
den pegelstand und passt seine ladung
dementsprechend an normalerweise haben
18 autos aus einer fähre in kaub platz
nicht so gut
sehen hier meter 20 und jeweils nochmal
30 haben ja media 80 wassertiefe setzt
natürlich voraus der boden glatt ist
also wir haben eine wassertiefe mit
unserem antrieb von einem media 20 setzt
wie gesagt immer voraus das alles gerade
ist aber man hat auch viel geschiebe im
rhein also steine die sich dann
fortbewegen und einsteigen mit 20 30 cm
durchmesser kann da schon zum verhängnis
werden
deshalb darf die fähre an diesem tag
höchstens zwölf autos auf einmal
transportieren ein verlustgeschäft
trotzdem ist es wichtig dass der
fährbetrieb aufrechterhalten bleibt die
nächste rheinbrücke ist fast 50
kilometer entfernt aber was wenn der
tiefstand zum dauerzustand wird
ob ich überhaupt das ganze was ich hier
besitze meine kinder noch mal weiter
vererben kann oder soll ob das sinn
macht das muss man halt alles sich
gedanken machen also es ist momentan
sehr schwierig überhaupt was zu sagen
oder zu machen
fällt einem schwer
das binnenschiff ms karl heim hat köln
passiert und geht auf die letzte etappe
bis mannheim die autoteile werden
rechtzeitig ankommen alles klappt auf
diesem törn
für die nahe zukunft wünsche ich mir
eigentlich dass es ein bisschen rechnet
dass das wasser wieder ein bisschen
steif wenn so ein halben meter wasser
wieder dabei kommt dann ist das für alle
beteiligten eigentlich viel besser dann
können die schiffe wieder deutlich mehr
laden und herren wir das für die
endverbraucher für die kunden wie der
transport dann natürlich auch wieder
etwas günstiger als das herz ist kurz
vor dem ziel gibt es noch ein
familientreffen auf dem wasser
ein verwandter ist in gegenrichtung
unterwegs
das jetzt mein onkel
bis heute
er fährt er wieder weg auf die familie
ist verlass auf den fluss und seinen
pegel nur noch bedingt wenn der
wassermangel anhält fährt die ms karl
hein einer schwierigen zukunft entgegen
[Musik]